[Music]
welcome back to our brown box today we
are test driving the Radeon rx 5600 XT
for the first time and I'm really hoping
I can make it through this lengthy
review without saying 5700 XT when I
really mean 5600 XT and not 5500 XT
anyway my small personal battles aside
aim D officially announced the 5600 XT
earlier this month at CES 2020 and
pretty much gave us all the important
information we got detailed specs
covering stuff such as the core count
the operating frequency memory
configuration pricing information and
even performance figures comparing the
5600 XT to competing products from
Nvidia and that really just left us
reviewers to confirm this information
our day 1 reviews and most of us got
busy doing just that about a week ago
though as is often the case when testing
new AMD products the process didn't go
all that smoothly but not for the usual
reasons it seems the problem was
generating heart by announcing basically
everything about an upcoming product is
that you're notifying a competition of
your plans in advance
essentially AMD gave him video two weeks
notice direct encounter the 5600 XT and
that's exactly what they did about a
week after the CES trade show Nvidia
dropped the price of their GeForce r-tx
2060 founders Edition model down to just
$300 us on their website that's a 14
percent discount from the original $350
us price EVGA also announced the KO
Edition pretty subtle name that one and
that also has a $300 u.s. MSRP it's hard
to know if this is a limited time only
price and at the time of creating this
video both the EVGA ko and in videos
found edition models are out of stock
making the cheapest available our TX
2060 about 320 dollars us whether or not
in videos price cut was just a ploy to
steal AMD's thunder didn't really matter
the result was always going to be the
same and it meant that AMD did need to
react or they'd be risking lackluster
day 1 reviews and this is because given
the specs that were announced at CES we
were pretty sure that the r-tx 2060 was
going to be around 10
sent faster than the 5600 XT but with
the price update it would only cost 7%
more and that would mean the 5600 XT was
going to be another dead on arrival Navi
GPU I'm of course talking about the 5500
XT here it would just be another
disaster for AMD so by announcing
pricing and specs ahead of time AMD have
pretty much played themselves on this
one and just made it all too easy for
NVIDIA an obvious solution to this mess
would have just been for AMD to reduce
pricing as they did with the 5700 series
but it seems as though AMD or either
unwilling or unable to do so
so the 5600 xt will remain at 280
dollars u.s. the less ideal and far
Messier option is to change the 5600 xt
spec by overclocking it for better
performance and this is exactly what AMD
has opted to do
shortly after reviewers received their
5600 XT samples AMD sent a panicked
email warning us that there would be a V
bias updating coming that would boost
performance quite substantially and
therefore any testing conducted prior to
the update would now be invalid
initially it wasn't clear if this was a
bug with the current bios but before
long it became clear what AMD was up to
realizing that the 5600 xt was going to
come up short
they've unofficially increased the core
clock by up to 15% and the memory
frequency by 17% now I say they've
increased the spec unofficially because
at CES AMD said the 5600 XT would
operate in a game clock of thirteen
hundred and seventy-five megahertz with
a boost clock of up to fifteen hundred
and 60 megahertz those numbers have now
technically increased to sixteen hundred
and fifty megahertz with a game clock
and 17 hundred and fifty megahertz for
the boost at least for the factory OC
models the six gigabytes of gddr5 speed
of twelve gigabits per second originally
- 14 gigabits per second for the final
updated spec again for the OSI models
this new OC ceiling which is intended to
allow the 5600 XT to tackle the cheaper
RT X 2060 models really is a significant
step up from the base spec typically
you'll see OC models
bringing around a three to five percent
performance increase when compared to
the reference spec at least this was the
case with the RX 5700 exterior range
here though the OSI models will be
around thirteen percent faster than base
models and we're talking about thirteen
percent faster on average not up to
thirteen percent faster so that really
is a significant difference it's also
worth noting that AMD sampled reviewers
exclusively using an OSI model and that
particular model is sapphires pulse but
we also have MSI's gaming acts along for
review as well the problem is there will
be models such as MSI's mecco C for
example which will be over ten percent
slower than the OSI models and they
might only be a ten dollar difference in
price so you really want to be careful
with which model you buy and this late
change has really created a big mess for
not just AMD and their partners but also
retailers and customers a number of AI
B's have confirmed with me that their
first wave of products have already
shipped prior to the changes made by AMD
and that means pretty much all 5600 XTS
available launch will have the original
BIOS and won't perform quite as well as
what's shown in most day 1 reviews so
that being the case I'll be showing 5600
XT results both before and after the
BIOS update and the before results
pretty much represent base spec
performance I have a few other concerns
about these changes but for now I think
it's time we just got into the results
and I'll talk about those concerns later
on the video for testing I'm using our
core o 999 hero K GPU test rig which
comes clocked at 5 gigahertz with 16
gigabytes of ddr4 3400 memory and the
exact graphics card models used for
testing will be in the description below
though please note the msi rx 5600 xt
gaming X was used exclusively for all
the 5600 xt testing in this video
finally we have 12 games to look at and
all have been tested at Tony P and 1440p
using medium to higher quality presets
or settings so let's get into the
results first up we have shut off the
Tomb Raider and here the updated version
of MSI 5600 XT gaming X model is a few
frames faster than the RT X 2060 you can
really see why the 5600 xt factory
overclocked sealing has been increased
as the 11 percent boost seen in the
title allows it to edge ahead of the
r-tx 2060 rather than trail it by an 8%
margin it's a similar story at 1440p
really though this time the r-tx 2060
manages to edge ahead of the 5,600 xt by
a single frame so it's pretty much a tie
before the upgrade the 5600 xt was 12%
slow in the r-tx 2060 so again you can
see why AMD needed to make the change
testing with assassin's creed Odyssey
saw the 5600 XT again match the RT X
2060 after the update and that means it
is just 6% slower than the RX 5700 and 7
percent slower than the 2060 super
identical performance between the 5600
XT and RT X 2060 can be seen at 1440p
and this time the new $280 Navy GPU is
just 8 percent slower than the rx 5,700
Nvidia strewing based GPUs have become
very competitive a Red Dead Redemption -
and in fact the RT X 2060 has now edged
ahead of the RX 5700 as a result of 5600
xt is quite a bit slower lagging behind
by a 16 percent margin using the higher
quality settings with d Vulkan API and
it's a similar story at 1440p though
this time the 5600 xt is 13% slower
still a pretty move Mahajan though then
when compared to the 5600 xt base back
the OSI model was 12% faster World of
Tanks is another title where the
cheering based GPUs and really NVIDIA
GPUs in general do really well the RT X
2060 for example that can be seen
matching the rx 5,700 this meant the OSI
version of the 5700 XT was 10% slower
while the base model was around 17
percent slower the margins do close up a
bit at 1440p here the 5,600 xt you see
was 6% slot in the r TX 2060 though base
models will still be around 16% slower
clearly the extra memory bandwidth is
playing a key role in boosting
performance of the OSI version far cry
new dawn results they're quite
interesting even the base spec 5600 XT
is very close to not just the r TX 2060
but also the RX 5700 clearly even with
the kora 999 ok there is some kind of
system bottleneck here jumping up to
1440p does see some separation and now
even the fact
Travie clocked 5,600 XT is slower than
the rx 5700 they're only by a 7% margin
it was also 7% faster in the RT X 2060
though the base spec is still a few
frames lower frame rates in Rainbow six
siege are very competitive here AMD's
last minute OVC update is enough to put
the 5600 XT on par with the RT X 2060
making it just 9% slower than the rx
5700 that said base model 5600 xt s will
trail the RT x 2060 by a 10% margin out
of the box
interestingly we see a situation at
1440p where Amy's 5600 xt falls behind
the r TX 2060 which appears to benefit
from superior memory compression
technology it's also strange to see the
5600 XT now matching the rx 5700 so
quite a surprising result here in Star
Wars Jedi fallen order the base 5600 XT
spec places at just ahead of the GTX
1660 super which is what we know AMD was
targeting originally with NVIDIA thar GX
2060 price cut that wouldn't it wouldn't
cut it
so the new OC ceiling puts the 5600 XT
on par with the 2060 super though it
also means that the 5600 XT is basically
able to offer rx 5700 light performance
in this title so that is something I
imagine AMD did want to avoid the 1440p
resolution does give the rx 5700 a
little more breathing room but even so
the factory overclocked 5600 XT was just
8% slower and 5% slower than the RT x
2060 next up we have battlefield fire
for the base model configuration C's the
5600 XT fall short of the r-tx 2060 by a
5 percent margin while the factory
received version was 3% faster it's a
very similar situation of 1440p though
it's interesting to note that even at
this higher resolution the factory
overclocked 5600 xt is still just 10%
slower than the RX 5700 here we see that
the 5600 xt OSI model will be able to
match the RT x 2060 internal such as
call of duty modern warfare where as
base models will be 8% slower it's
pretty much the same story at 1440p
and here the 5600 xt OC cards are just
8% slower than the RX 5700 the higher
ensuring GPUs do seem to suffer
from weaker-than-expected frame time
performance in Metro Exodus when using
the ultra quality settings the r-tx 2060
for example is quite a bit slower than
the 5600 XT in that regard even when
compared to the base model again the
5600 XT OC isn't a great deal slower
than the rx 5700 this time just 10%
slower at 1080p the jump up to 1440p
really does result in similar margins
they overclocked 5600 XT is just 9%
slower than the rx 5700 while it was 12%
faster than the RT X 2060 when comparing
the average frame rate the second last
game we're going to look at is F 1 2019
here the 5,600 XT OC was almost at the
same level as the RT X 2060 super and
that meant it was 7% faster than the
standard RT x 2060 we also see a 9%
performance boost from the base back to
the factory OC versions of the 5600 XT
once again we find a similar situation
at 1440p and it really is impressive to
see the 5,600 XT trailing the rx 5700 by
just a 6% margin finally we have Gears
of War 5 and here the base spec 5600 XT
average to 81 FPS while the factory OC
spec was 12% faster the RT x 2060 does
well here and it's just able to edge out
the rx 5700 which meant it was 11
percent faster than the 5,600 xt o see
here we see that the six gigabyte 5600
xt i'm just bringing up 6 gigabyte
because that's the frame buffer size
there's no 8 gigabyte or 4 gigabyte
version it's just 6 gigabytes but anyway
it does fall away a little bit 1440p as
here it was 11% slower than the RX 5700
and 13 percent slower than the RT x 2060
power consumption is obviously a big
advantage of these newer 7 nanometre
navi gps at least when compared to
previous radeon gpus when compared to in
videos cheering GPUs the factory
overclocked 5600 xt is still very
efficient offering a similar level of
performance while saving around 20 watts
of total system power ok so that's how
the base model in factory overclocked
Radeon rx 5600 HD graphics cards will
perform now it's time to see how they
stack up overall and then of course take
a look at our cost per frame data right
so
on average at 1080p the msi 5600 xt
gaming x and RT x 2060 which is also a
factory OSI model from msi called the
gaming zed they delivered the exact same
performance this also means on average
factory overclocked 5600 xt models will
be around 10 percent faster than base
models so a pretty big difference there
out of the box we can also see that the
base model 5600 xt s do have the gtx
1660 super cover does AMD promised
delivering 13% more performance on
average meanwhile the overclocked 5600
xt was just 7% slower than the RX 5700
on average while the MSRP is 20% lower
realistically the OSI models will
probably be around 15% cheaper even at
1440p the overclocked MSI gaming
versions of the RT X 2016 and 5600 XT
are evenly matched base model cards will
be 10% slower but of course you can
manually overclock those anyway ok so
time for our cost per frame analysis and
first let's just compare the MSI gaming
versions of the 5600 XT and r-tx 2060
given both delivered 125 FPS on average
it's pretty obvious which model wins
here I'm expecting the gaming X version
of the 5600 XT to be priced at least $20
over MSRP just as the RT X 2060 gaming
Zed model is I've also included two
prices for the RT X 2060 gaming Zed the
370 dollar us listing is the current
retail price that's how I'm making this
video whereas the second alleged price
with the $50 discount is what we're yet
to see but hoping to see any case even
with the $50 price cut the RT X 2060
gaming set will still cost seven percent
more than the 5,600 XT gaming X however
at current prices the GeForce card cost
32% more making the 5,600 XT a vastly
superior choice in terms of value so
there you have it what I suppose is an
apples-to-apples AIB comparison now
here's a look at the cost per frame data
Frawley currently available GPUs that
were tested
please note we have to RTX 2060 prices
the $330 price represents the cheapest
currently available model while the $300
price represents the EVGA ko and nvidia
fe models even though right now
they're not in stock then we have to
performance and price configurations for
the 5600 XT there's the base model at
the MSRP and then an OC performance
version which I believe will come in at
at least a 10 dollar premium for models
such as the sapphire pulse which I also
have on hand for testing and it delivers
the same performance as Emma sized
gaming X version the best value option
here will be the cheaper o receiver
jhin's at ten dollars over the MSRP
again such as the pulse basically I
think it's fair to say you'll want to
ensure that you're buying an OSI model
as the base models are pretty poor value
and yes you can overclock them but they
will likely come with pretty weak
coolers so I think it is better off
spending two hundred and ninety two
three hundred dollars us on a better
quality model the RT X 2060 is decent
value at three hundred dollars but
realistically right now you are looking
at having to spend at least three
hundred and thirty two three hundred and
fifty dollars again at the time of
making this video which makes the 5600
XT a much better value choice in either
configuration which is what AMD was
betting on from the get-go
it's also worth pointing out that the
GTX 1660s super still stacks up really
well here in terms of value and while
base model 5600 XTS might be 24% faster
in terms of cost per frame the 1660
super is a little better well in short
the radio rx 5600 XT is a decent product
it won't blow your socks off but it
offers a little more value in the 250 to
$300 price range it's also better value
than the Radeon rx 5700 and makes the RT
X 2060 super are really tough buy if it
wasn't already given the competition in
this price range
I think aim D has done okay but again
not amazing certainly not going to blow
you away but it is an improvement and
certainly better than what I thought we
might have ended up with especially
given what the 5500 XT offered at the
two hundred to one hundred and seventy
dollar price point the main advantage of
the more expensive rx 5700 is the extra
two year bites of VRAM which depending
on the games you play the quality
settings you like to use and the
resolution that may or may not factor
into your buying decision and a lot of
people will complain about the six
gigabyte variant buffer and I certainly
get where you're coming from and I tend
to agree that eight gigabytes really
should be the minimum into
20 especially for a card price near $300
u.s. but at least for now it won't
really matter for 1080p gaming so
overall it's decent but let's talk more
about how AMD handled this release the
last-minute decision to raise the
ceiling on the AIB OC models was a
desperate move that's going to cause a
few teething issues as I said I know
pretty much all AI bees have shipped
their first batch of 5600 XTS
and none of them feature the updated
bias so that is going to be a very messy
and frustrating process for all involved
how these updates are handled and who
takes care of the process will depend on
probably the brand the region and then
even the retailer tech savvy users can
just download the updated bias
themselves and then apply it in a few
seconds but others will require
third-party to support them or they'll
probably just simply not bother and miss
out on that extra 10% or so performance
you could always manually overclock but
that's a less elegant sort of solution
and frankly I don't find GPU
overclocking all that practical
initially I was concerned with how well
most 5,600 XT graphics cars would handle
the increased factory overclock but
after asking around it seems like most
babies have simply used their 5,700
series coolers so there should be plenty
of headroom and AMD say this is
something they carefully evaluated
before making the change
still I'm interested to see which models
get the overclock and which ones are
stuck at the much slower much lower base
clock so that's something will no doubt
get to explore over the coming weeks I'm
also interested to see how many are TX
2060 models actually hit $300 and when
stock will return for the EVGA ko and
nvidia fe models i'm almost expecting
this to be a very limited run deal just
to steal AMD's thunder i guess
worst-case it forced a me to make the
5600 XT a little closer to the 5700 and
they would have liked to so probably not
a bad thing something I haven't touched
on yet is overclocking basically because
the OC headroom went from hero to zero
as it stands the factory overclocked
models like the pulse and gaming X can
be pushed to around 1820 megahertz for
the core so yeah a further four percent
frequency bump while you can squeeze
that more frequency and if the memory
using soft power played tables that will
be possible to go higher and this is
something I'll probably explore shortly
but as far as more convenient
overclocking goes the things pretty well
tapped out
finally it's good to see some more
competition in the GPU space and I'm
sure once we finally have competition at
all price points things really will heat
up on that note if AMD could optimize
the way they release information I feel
that would also benefit them probably
don't show your hand weeks in advance
but I also appreciate not having to race
around and get pricing last-minute
usually half a day before reviews go
live so somewhere between half a day and
two weeks would probably be more optimal
so that's probably something AMD you can
look into for future releases anyway
that is going to do it for this one hope
you guys enjoyed this review if you did
you know what to do and if you'd like to
get more involved with the higher on box
channel then you can join us over on
patreon get access to our monthly live
streams discord chat and a few other
cool perks you can check that out links
in the video description I also have
merch so yeah check that out if you're
interested
hey that's gonna do it for this one
thank you for watching I'm your host
Steve and I'll see you again next time
much respect
[Music]